Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This is a neural network-based technique that
can perform audio-visual separation.
Before we talk about what that is, I will
tell you what it is not.
It is not what we've seen in the previous
episode where we could select a pixel and
listen to it, have
a look.
This one is different.
This new technique can clean up an audio signal
by suppressing the noise in a busy bar, even
if the source of the noise is not seen in
the video.
It can also enhance the voice of the speaker
at the same time.
Let's listen.
Or, if we have a skype-meeting with someone
in a lab or a busy office where multiple people
are speaking nearby, we can also perform a
similar speech separation, which would be
a godsend for future meetings.
And I think if you are a parent, the utility
this example needs no further explanation.
I am not sure if I ever encountered the term
"screaming children" in the abstract of an
AI paper, so that one was also a first here.
This is a super difficult task, because the
AI needs to understand what lip motions correspond
to what kind of sounds, which is different
for all kinds of languages, age groups, and
head positions.
To this end, the authors put together a stupendously
large dataset with almost 300.000 videos with
clean speech signals.
This dataset is then run through a multi-stream
neural network that detects the number of
human faces within the video, generates small
thumbnails of them, and observes how they
move over time.
It also analyzes the audio signal separately,
then fuses these elements together with a
recurrent neural network to output the separated
audio waveforms.
A key advantage of this architecture and training
method is that as opposed to many previous
works, this is speaker-independent, therefore
we don't need specific training data from
the speaker we want to use this on.
This is a huge leap in terms of usability.
The paper also contains an excellent demonstration
of this concept by taking a piece of footage
from Conan O'Brien's show where two comedians
were booked for the same time slot and talk
over each other.
The result is a performance where it is near
impossible to understand what they are saying,
but with this technique, we can hear both
of them one by one, crystal clear.
You see some results over here, but make sure
to click the paper link in the description
to hear the sound samples as well.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!